The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today's lesson will
complete our first excursion
into the subject
of linear algebra
for the sake of linear algebra.
And next time, we will
turn our attention
to applications of linear
algebra and linear equations
and the like, to applications
towards functions
of several variables in the
cases where the functions are
not necessarily linear.
Now, you may recall
that we concluded
our last lesson on the note of
talking about inverse matrices,
pointing out that an
inverse matrix existed,
provided that the determinant
of the entries making up
the matrix was not 0, otherwise,
the inverse matrix didn't
exist, but that we then
said, once we know this,
how do we actually construct
the inverse matrix?
And what I hope to
do in today's lesson
is to show you a rather elegant
manner for inverting a matrix,
and at the same time, to point
out several other consequences
that will be helpful in
our study of calculus
of several variables in
other contexts as we proceed.
At a rate, today's
lessons is called quite
simply "Inverting a Matrix."
And to start with a specific
example in front of us, let's
invert the matrix
A inverse, where
A is the matrix whose entries
are 1, 1, 1; 2, 3, 4; 3, 4, 6.
Keep in mind, among
the various ways
of motivating matrix
algebra, we chose
as our particular
illustration the coding system
of the matrix representing
the coefficients in a system
of m equations with n unknowns.
In this particular case
of a 3 by 3 matrix,
we view the matrix A
as coding the system
of three linear equations
and three unknowns,
given by system 1.
I call it equation 1.
We have this system of three
equations with three unknowns.
By the way, observe that this
looks very much like a problem
that we tackled in high
school, except for one
very small change.
In high school, you may remember
that we tackled equations
of the form like this,
provided that the y's
were replaced by constants.
In other words, we weren't used
to thinking of linear systems
of equations in terms
of functions this way,
but we were used to thinking of
things like x_1 plus x_2 plus
x_3 equals 2, 2*y_1 plus
3*x_2 plus 4*x_3 equals 9.
3*x_1 plus 4*x_2
plus 6*x_3 equals 13.
And then the question
was to solve specifically
for x_1, x_2, and x_3.
All right?
Now, the only difference
we're making now
is that we're not
going to specify
what y_1, y_2, and y_3 are.
We'll mention the relationship
between our problem
and the high school one
later in the lecture.
But what we are saying is this.
We would like, in general, given
these three equations and three
unknowns, this system
of linear equations,
we would like to be able to
solve for the x's in terms
of the y's.
And that is what I'm going
to show you is identified
with inverting the matrix.
What I hope to show you as we
go along is that if the matrix A
represents these coefficients,
assuming that we find
the technique whereby
we can express uniquely
for the x's in terms of the y's,
the coefficients that express
the x's as linear combinations
of the y's-- those coefficients
involving the y's-- will
turn out to be A inverse.
We'll talk about
that more later.
I simply wanted to
tell you that now
so that you'd have a head start
into what my plan of attack
is going to be.
First of all, let me
mention a method which
you may have seen
previously in school,
but a very effective method
for systematizing or solving
systems of linear equations
in a way that works very, very
systematically.
The idea is something like this.
We know that if we replace
one equation-- well, let's
put it this way.
If we add equals to equals,
the results are equal.
If we multiply equals
by equals, the results
are equal, et cetera.
Consequently, given a system
of equations like this,
we know that if we replace
one of the equations
by that equation plus a
multiple of any other equation,
you see-- if we add two
equations together, things
of this type, where, as
we change the system,
we don't change the
solutions to the system.
In other words,
there are devices
whereby we can
systematically replace
the given system of
equations, hopefully,
by simpler systems of
equations where the simpler
system of equations has
the same set of solutions
as the original system.
And the method that I'm thinking
of is called diagonalization.
For example, what we often
say is something like this.
We say, lookit, wouldn't
it be nice to get
a system in which x_1 appears
only in the first equation?
And one way of
doing that, notice,
is we observe that in
the second equation,
we have 2*x_1 In the first
equation, we have x_1.
If we were to subtract twice the
first equation from the second
equation and use that for
our new second equation,
notice that the new second
equation would have no x_1 term
in it, because 2*x_1
minus 2*x_1 is 0.
Similarly, since the leading
term in the third equation is
3*x_1 we observe that if we
were to subtract three times
the first equation
from the third,
the resulting third equation
would have no x_1 term in it,
so that the new system would
have x_1 in the first equation
and no place else.
Similarly, we could move over
now to our new second equation,
and then eliminate x_2 from
every equation but the second
by subtracting off the
appropriate multiple
of the second equation.
Now, what I'm
going to do here is
that, since it gets kind of
messy working with the y_1's,
y_2's, and y_3's
and it stretches
out all over the
place, let me invent
a new type of coding system.
I will take these three
equations and three unknowns
and represent it by a 3
by 6 matrix as follows.
I will start up with the
following coding system.
I will use place value.
The first three columns will
represent x_1, x_2, x_3,
respectively.
The next three columns will
represent y_1, y_2, and y_3,
respectively.
I'll assume an equal
sign divides this.
And this will simply be a
coding device for reading what?
x_1 plus x_2 plus
x_3 equals y_1.
2*x_1 plus 3*x_2 plus
4*x_3 equals y_2.
3*x_1 plus 4*x_2 plus
6*x_3 equals y_3.
Notice why I say y_3.
It's 0*y_1 plus 0*y_2 plus
1*y_3, which, of course,
is y_3.
Notice also that the left
side of this 3 by 6 matrix
is precisely the matrix A that
we're investigating back here.
I just want that for
future reference.
Now, let me go through
this procedure.
What I will now do is subtract
twice the first equation
from the second and make
that my new second one.
And I will subtract three
times the first equation
from the third to give me
my new third equation, which
means, in terms of
the matrix notation,
that I am replacing the
second row of this matrix
by the second row minus
twice the first row.
I'm replacing the third row by
the third row minus three times
the first row.
I now wind up with this
particular 3 by 6 matrix.
Again, just by brief review,
what this matrix system tells
me, for example, is,
among other things,
that x_2 plus 2*x_3 is
minus 2*y_1 plus y_2.
You see, not only do I
have a coding system here,
but the right-hand
side allows me
to check how I got the resulting
matrix on the left hand side.
It tells me how the y's had
to be combined to give me this
combination of the x's.
At any rate, I now
want to eliminate 1
every place in the second
column except in the second row.
So looking at this matrix
now, what I will do
is I will replace the first row
by the first minus the second--
see, 1 minus 1 is 0.
So my new first row
will have a 0 here.
I will then replace
the third row
by the third minus the
second, again, meaning what?
That my new third row
will have a 0 here.
Leaving the details for
you to check for yourself,
the resulting 3 by 6
matrix now looks like this.
By the way, again notice
what this tells me.
Among other things,
this tells me
that x_3 is minus y_1
minus y_2 plus y_3, which
somehow tells me
that to find x_3,
I essentially have to do what?
I can subtract the sum of
the first and second equation
from the third equation,
and that will give me x_3.
By the way, just as a
quick look over here,
just to show you how
nice this technique is,
maybe somebody who had been very
quick could have looked at this
system of equations
and said, you know,
if I add the first
two equations,
this will give me a 3*x_1,
this will give me a 4*x_2,
and therefore, if I subtract
that from the third equation,
the x_1 term and the x_2 terms
will drop out, et cetera.
The thing I want to point out
is that this matrix system
makes geniuses out of
all of us, that we do not
have to be able to see these
intricacies to be able to get
down to a stage like this.
By the way, again,
what this tells me is
I now have a simpler method for
solving this original system
of equations.
Namely, I can now
solve this system
of equations-- the one
that's coded by this--
and the solutions
of this equation
will be the same
set as the solutions
to my original equation.
At any rate, continuing this
diagonalization method still
more, what I now do is
I try to replace what?
In the third column, I
try to get 0's everywhere
except in the third row.
And to put that in
still other words,
I guess, in the
language of matrices,
what I'm going to try
to do is get what?
The three by three
identity matrix
to make up the first
half over here--
that's in terms of
the matrix language.
Now again, to show you quickly
what I'm trying to do here,
I'm simply going
to what over here?
I'm going to replace
the first row
by the first plus the third.
I'm going to replace the
second row by the second row
minus twice the third.
I now wind up with
this particular matrix.
I claim that the
right half-- see,
the left half of this matrix
is the identity matrix.
I claim that the left half
I calm the right
half is A inverse.
That's what my claim is.
And by the way, let's
see why I say that.
What system of equations
does A inverse code?
Just read what this says.
It says x_1 is equal to
2*y_1 minus 2*y_2 plus y_3.
x_2 is equal to y_2 minus 2*y_3.
And x_3 is minus y_1
minus y_2 plus y_3.
In other words, A inverse
codes this particular system.
Let's call that system 2.
How are system 2 and what
we call system 1 related?
The relationship was that system
1 expressed the y's in terms
of the x's.
System 2 shows what it would
look like if the x's were
expressed in terms of the y's.
And so what we have done, in the
language of-- whatever you want
to call it-- but what we've
done is we've inverted the role
of the variables, that we
started with the y's given
in terms of the x's.
We now have the x's expressed
in terms of the y's.
Now, since you may want to see
this more in matrix language,
let me show you another way of
seeing the same result, that
uses the word inverse
in the way we're
used to seeing
inverse matrix defined
in terms of our present course.
The matrix algebra
interpretation is simply this.
Let's rewrite system 1 so
that you can see it here.
And the interesting
point is the following.
Think of these y's as forming
a column vector or column
matrix-- whichever way you
want to read this thing.
In other words, I am
going to view this
as being the matrix which has
three rows and one column,
namely the matrix y_1 y_2, y_3.
I am now going to take the
matrix of coefficients here,
which, as we recall, is the
matrix A. But that's what?
[1, 1, 1; 2, 3, 4; 3, 4, 6].
And I am now going to write
x_1, x_2, x_3 as a column vector
rather than as a row vector.
And in turn, I can think of
that as being a column matrix--
again, 3 by 1 matrix--
three rows, one column.
Now, what I claim is that
this system of three equations
and three unknowns,
so to speak, is
equivalent to the single
matrix equation given by this.
In fact, to make
this easier to read,
let's let capital Y denote the
column matrix [y 1; y2; y3].
Let's let capital X denote the
column matrix [x 1; x2; x3],
and capital A, as before,
the original matrix.
And my claim is that this system
of three equations and three
unknowns is represented by
the single matrix equation
capital Y equals A times
capital X. And just
to show you by way of
a very quick review why
this is the case, remember
how we multiply two matrices.
To find the term in the
first row, first column,
we multiply the first
row of the first
by the first column
of the second.
And since that's supposed
to equal this matrix,
and since matrices are
equal only if they're
equal entry by entry, it
means that this product
must equal y_1.
Notice what that says.
It says x_1 plus x_2
plus x_3 equals y_1.
Similarly, 2 times x_1 plus
3 times x_2 plus 4 times x_3
is going to have to equal y_2.
And similarly, 3 times x_1 plus
4 times x_2 plus 6 times x_3
is going to have to equal y_3.
And that's precisely the
original system of equations
that we began with.
Now, notice that this expresses
the matrix Y as something times
the matrix X. If
A inverse exists,
multiply both sides of this
matrix equation by A inverse.
On the left hand side,
we get A inverse Y.
On the right-hand side,
A inverse times A*X,
by associativity, is
A inverse A times X.
A inverse times A is
the identity matrix.
The identity matrix doesn't
change the given matrix
that it's multiplying.
So we have that A
inverse Y is just X.
And notice that the
role of A inverse
is, again, just as mentioned
above, that what we've done
is we have started with
Y given as a matrix times
X. We now have X expressed
as a matrix times
Y. In fact, if you now take
the matrix that we called
A inverse originally and
carry out this operation,
we will see that this is
precisely what does happen.
This is what the
identification is.
In other words, the
system of equations
is identifiable with a
single matrix equation.
And that matrix equation
can be inverted,
meaning we can solve for X
in terms of Y if and only
if A inverse exists.
There is still a
third interpretation,
an interpretation that goes
back to the idea of mappings.
And that is, we can think
of the original system
1 as a mapping that carries
three-dimensional space
into three-dimensional space.
How does it carry
three-dimensional space
into three-dimensional space?
Well, we view it as carrying
the 3-tuple (x_1, x_2, x_3)
into the 3-tuple (y_1, y_2,
y_3) by the system of equations
defined by system 1.
And to show you what I mean
by that in more detail,
suppose I pick x_1 to be 1,
x_2 to be 1, x_3 to be 1.
Just for the sake of argument,
suppose I picked that.
x_1, x_2, x_3 are all 1.
What this means is-- lookit.
Come back to the
original system,
replace x_1, x_2, and x_3 by 1.
If we do that, we see that y_1
is 3, y_2 is 9, and y_3 is 13.
Therefore, we would say what?
That f bar maps (1,
1, 1) into (3, 9, 13).
By the way, you're going to
notice this sooner or later.
This bothered me when
I first did this.
This is just a little aside.
You may have noticed that when
I was arbitrarily writing down
numbers to pick for y_1, y_2,
and y_3, when we first started
at the beginning
of the lecture, I
said why don't we let y_1 be
2, y_2 be 9, and y_3 be 13.
And it looks almost
like I made a mistake
and meant to get (2,
9, 13) back again.
I got (3, 9, 13).
Notice that to get (2, 9, 13), I
couldn't pick x_1, x_2, and x_3
all to be 1, but I could
pick x_1 to be minus 1,
x_2 to be 1, x_3 to be 2.
And then what that says is
if I let x_1 be minus 1,
x_2 be plus 1, and
x_3 be 3, it says
that, under those conditions,
y_1 would have been 2,
y_2 would have been 9, and
y_3 would have been 13.
Of course, the question
that you now may ask,
which I hope gives you some sort
of a cross reference to go by,
is how did I know?
See, starting with
(1, 1, 1), it seemed
very easy to find
the image (3, 9, 13).
Now, I say, starting
with the image,
how do I find that this is
what mapped into (2, 9, 13)?
How did I know?
See, here it was easy.
I started with the input x bar.
But here, I'm starting
with the output
and I'm trying to
find the input.
How did I find (-1,
1, 2) that fast?
And the answer is that's
precisely where the role
of the inverse matrix comes in.
You see, going back to what
we did just a little while
ago, when we inverted
system 1 to get system 2,
what did we do?
We showed how to find x_1,
x_2, x_3 once y_1, y_2,
and y_3 were given.
So all I had to do here was,
knowing that I wanted y_1
to be 2, y_2 to be
9, and y_3 to be 13,
I just shoved those
values in here
and saw what x_1,
x_2, and x_3 were.
In fact, this is why working
with the y's is an improvement
over what the high school
system was of picking
the y's to be constant.
You see, once I've
done this, I can
find what x_1, x_2, x_3 look
like in terms of the y's,
all in one shot, regardless
of what values of y somebody
is going to give me to
play around with later on.
But returning now to our
immediate problem, notice,
all I'm saying is that when
I'm given a system of n
linear equations and
n unknowns, or even
n equations and
unknowns-- in this case
we had three linear equations
and three unknowns--
I can view that in a very
natural way as a mapping
from three-dimensional space
into three-dimensional space.
Notice that the makers of
coefficients A and the mapping
f bar-- and I'll
coin a word here,
because I don't know exactly
how I want you to see this--
but they're identifiable.
They're essentially equivalent.
Notice that, given x bar,
I want to apply f bar
to that to find y bar.
Notice that, in terms
of our matrix language,
we show that, after
all, the matrix capital
Y, which had entries
y_1, y_2, y_3,
is just a different numeral
for writing this vector.
This is a 3-tuple.
This is the same 3-tuple written
as a column rather as a row.
x bar is a 3-tuple, but
capital X that same 3-tuple
written as a column vector
rather than as a row vector.
But notice that
the identification
that if y bar is f
bar of x bar, that
says the same information
as saying that capital Y
is the matrix A times capital X.
These convey equivalent
pieces of information.
In still other words,
notice that, in finding
the images of f bar here
and inverting the images,
I used precisely the same
device that I used in the system
without giving the
mapping interpretation.
In other words, these do
convey the same information
so that from a
major point of view,
we can identify the matrix
A with the mapping f bar.
And you see, what this means
is that if we can identify
A with f bar, we should be
able to identify A inverse
with the inverse function.
See, that's the other way
we've used the word "inverse"--
as an inverse function.
The existence of A inverse is
equivalent to the existence
of f bar inverse.
And by the way, we showed that.
You see, using the system of
equations that we started with,
we showed that if x_1
is minus 1, x_2 is 1,
and x_3 is 2, that y_1
would be 2, y_2 would be 9,
and y_3 would be 13.
We also showed that if we
start with y_1 equals 2,
y_2 equals 9, and
y_3 equals 13, then
the x's had to be given
by minus 1, 1, and 2.
In terms of the mapping,
what we're saying
is not only does (-1, 1, 2) map
into (2, 9, 13), but (2, 9, 13)
can only be obtained from
the 3-tuple (-1, 1, 2).
You see, in essence, in
this particular case,
the existence of
A inverse showed
that f bar was onto-- we could
get any 3-tuple we wanted--
and it was also one-to-one.
The important point, in terms
of our theory of matrices,
is that, since f bar inverse
need not exist for a given f,
A inverse need not exist for a
given matrix A. In other words,
if we're identifying the
matrix with the function,
if the inverse
function doesn't exist,
the inverse matrix
doesn't exist.
In other words, not all
matrices are invertible.
And let's emphasize that.
We knew that from before,
but let's emphasize this now
in terms of our structure.
Namely, let's take
a new example.
Let's try to invert a matrix
which doesn't have an inverse.
Obviously, if I try to do
that, I should fail dismally.
And let's see how
that does work out.
Let me take the matrix A to be
[1, 1, 1; 2, 3, 4; 3, 4, 5].
I deliberately
called this A again,
even though we've used A before.
I've deliberately made
this A look very much
like the A we
worked with before.
If you compare this
with our original A,
the only difference is I now
have a 5 here rather than a 6.
I simply wanted to show you
how a subtle change can affect
the existence of an inverse.
Again, by way of
very quick review,
before we go any further,
notice that this matrix
codes what system of equations?
This particular
system of equations.
And so that you don't
see any hanky-panky
going on here and wondering why
I knew that something was going
to go wrong here, let
me show you in advance
why I can't invert this, then
show you how our matrix coding
system gives us the
same information,
even if we weren't bright
enough to see this.
Just for the sake of argument,
suppose I had a keen enough eye
to observe right away that if I
added the first two equations,
I would get that y_1
plus y_2 is what?
3*x_1 plus 4*x_2 plus 5*x_3.
And now I look at
this result, compare
that with my third equation
where the right-hand sides
are identical, and
conclude from this
that this is not really three
equations with three unknowns.
This is really two equations
with three unknowns,
because this equation here
is either redundant or
incompatible, meaning, notice
that these two facts tell me
that y_1 plus y_2
has to equal y_3.
To show you what I
mean by that, let
me pick specific values for
y_1, y_2, and y_3, in which y_3
is not equal to y_1 plus y_2.
And to keep this as
close to the problem
that we were working
with originally,
let me pick y_1 to be 2, y_2
to be 9, and y_3 to be 13.
Notice that this system of
equations cannot possibly have
a solution now.
This system of equations
here cannot possibly have
a solution, because if it had a
solution, it would imply what?
That if I add these
two equations,
it would say that 3*x_1 plus
4*x_2 plus 5*x_3 equals 11--
if I add these two equations.
That would say it
also has to equal 13.
And since 11 is
equal to 13-- and I
have to correct a mistake I
made in an earlier lecture--
it's for large values of
11 that 11 is equal to 13.
But other than that,
11 is unequal to 13.
This means that it's
impossible to find solutions
to this equation.
Well, we'll come back to
that in a little while
and we'll also emphasize
this in the exercises.
But the main point
now is to show
how we could have obtained
this information by our matrix
coding system.
And we do exactly the same
thing as we did before.
We take this matrix and
we augment it by the 3
by 3 identity matrix.
Remember again, what our coding
system says is that the first
three columns represent the
x's, the next three the y's.
For example, this says
x_1 plus x_2 plus x_3
equals y_1, et cetera.
We now go through what I call
the row reducing operations,
which means what?
We're going to replace rows
by the rows plus or minus
a suitable multiple of another
row so that we do what?
We wind up with a 1, eventually,
only here and 0's elsewhere,
a 1 here, 0's here, a 1 here and
0's here-- if we can do that.
Let's see what happens here.
What I'm going to
do, of course, is
I'm going to replace
the second row here
by the second minus
twice the first.
I'll replace the third row
by the third minus 3 times
the first.
I now wind up with
this equivalent matrix,
that this matrix codes the
same system of equations
as the original matrix.
Now, I'm going to replace the
first row by the first row
minus the second.
I will replace the third row by
the third row minus the second.
And since I already
have a 1 in here,
I will leave the
second row intact.
And if I do that, I now wind
up with this 3 by 6 matrix.
And now a very
interesting thing has
happened-- maybe
alarming, maybe unhappy,
but nonetheless interesting.
I observe that on the left-hand
side of my 3 by 6 matrix here,
I have a row consisting entirely
of 0's, that in row reducing
this, I have lost any chance
of getting a 1 over here
because this whole
row has dropped out.
See, one of two things had
to happen when I row reduced.
Either, when I finished, I would
have had the identity matrix
here, or else I would have
had, in this left-hand half,
at least one row of 0's.
In this case, I got
the one row of 0's.
Let's translate what
this thing says.
It says x_1 minus x_3
is 3*y_1 minus y_2.
x_2 plus 2*x_3 is
minus 2*y_1 plus y_2.
And it also says that what?
0*x_1 plus 0*x_2 plus
0*x_3-- in other words, 0--
is equal to minus y_1
minus y_2 plus y_3.
And let's write that
to emphasize this.
You see, what we really have
from the first two equations
is this system here-- two
equations but in three
unknowns-- x_1, x_2, x_3.
We're assuming that
the y's are knowns now.
The third piece of
information I've
written in an accentuated
form to emphasize the fact
that the third equation tells
us under what conditions
we're in trouble as far as
the choice of the y's are
concerned.
Namely, what this tells
us is that minus y_1
minus y_2 plus y_3 has to
be 0 to be able to solve
the system at all.
That's the same as
saying, of course,
that y_3 is y_1 plus y_2.
So the first thing
we know is that,
unless y_3 equals y_1 plus
y_2, we cannot express
the x's in terms of the y's.
Why can't we express them?
The system is incompatible.
That's exactly, by the way,
what we observed over here.
Only now, we don't have to
be that bright to notice it.
See, here we have
to astutely observe
that the third equation was
the sum of the first two.
Our matrix coding system told us
right away that what went wrong
here was that y_3
equals y_1 plus y_2.
So unless y_3
equals y_1 plus y_2,
we cannot express the
x's in terms of the y's.
The second thing
that goes wrong is
that even if y_3 equals y_1
plus y_2-- then, for example,
we still can't express the
x's in terms of the y's,
because-- I say
"for example" here,
because I could have
picked any of the x's
as far as that's concerned.
But for example, x_3 is
independent of y_1 and y_2.
I add "and y3" in
parentheses here,
because notice, in
the second case,
y_3 is not independent
of y_1 and y_2.
y_3 is equal to y_1 plus y_2,
so it's automatically specified
as soon as I know y_1 and y_2.
But here what I'm saying.
If I now take this
result here and come back
to this system of
equations, assuming
that y_1 plus y_2 is y_3 so that
I now have this constraint here
met, notice that I can pick
x_3 completely at random,
independently of what the
values of y_1 and y_2 are,
and solve for x_1 and x_2.
In other words, I have a
degree of freedom here.
The x's are not completely
determined by the y's.
One of the x's can
be chosen at random.
It floats around.
OK, so you see what goes wrong
here from the point of view
of inverting the equations?
If the constraint, meaning y_3
equals y_1 plus y_2 is not met,
you can't invert at all.
The system is incompatible.
If the constraint is met,
the x's aren't completely
determined by the y's.
You can pick one of
the x's at random,
and then solve for
the remaining two.
Now, what does
this mean in terms
of our function interpretation?
And I think you may enjoy
this, because I think
it'll show things very nicely.
What it means, for
example, is this.
Suppose I now look
at the mapping that's
defined by the
system of equations
that we were just talking about.
Notice that what we're saying
is that, unless y_3 equals
y_1 plus y_2, there's
no hope of finding
x's that solve that
particular equation.
In other words, if it turns
out, given this mapping,
that y bar is (1, 1, 3),
then there is no x bar such
that f bar of x bar
is equal to y bar,
because 3 is
unequal to 1 plus 1.
You see, again,
what we're saying,
in terms of the mapping
here, is to get a solution,
the y's have to be no
longer arbitrary, but chosen
to satisfy a
specific constraint.
And in the system of
equations 3 that we
dealt with in this case,
that constraint was y_3
equals y_1 plus y_2.
In other words, what this
means in terms of the mapping
is that f bar is not onto.
See, notice, the equation
wasn't invertible.
A inverse didn't exist.
Therefore, f bar
inverse shouldn't exist,
and for f bar
inverse not to exist,
it's sufficient that f bar
be either not onto, or else
not one-to-one.
And we have now shown that f
bar is not onto, because nothing
maps into (1, 1, 3).
We can go one step
further and show
that even if the
constraint is met--
suppose we pick
a y bar where y_3
is equal to y_1 plus y_2,
for example, (1, 1, 2).
See, 2 is equal to 1 plus 1.
Then the system of equations
that we had before applies.
What was that system of
equations that we had before?
It was x_1 minus x_3
equals 3*y_1 minus y_2.
x_2 plus 2*x_3 equals
minus 2*y_1 plus y_2.
The third equation
wasn't an equation.
It was the constraint
that required
that y_3 equals y_1 plus y_2.
So that's been met.
So we now down to what?
Two equations in three
unknowns-- first of all,
let's take a look and see
what happens over here.
In this case, y_1 is 1.
y_2 is 1.
So x_1 minus x_3 is simply 2.
x_2 plus 2*x_3 is
simply minus 1.
I can now pick x_3 at random
and solve for x_1 and x_2
in terms of that, namely, what?
x_1 is simply x_3 plus 2, and
x_2 is minus 2*x_3 minus 1.
In other words,
what this tells me
is that a whole bunch of vectors
are mapped into (1, 1, 2).
A whole bunch of 3-tuples-- if
you want to use word "3-tuple"
rather than vector-- are
mapped into (1, 1, 2) by f bar.
How are those vectors chosen?
Well, you can pick the
third component at random,
in which case, the
first component, x_1,
is simply x_3 plus 2, and
the second component, x_2,
is simply minus 2*x_3 minus 1,
where the x_3 is the value that
you chose here.
Since there are infinitely
many ways of choosing x_3,
there are infinitely
many 3-tuples
that map into (1, 1, 2).
In particular, f bar is
not one-to-one either,
which means, in terms of
a picture-- and in fact,
let's see how we can work
this very comfortably.
Why not pick x_3 to
be 0 for a start?
If we pick x_3 to be 0,
notice that this 3-tuple
becomes (2, -1, 0).
So (2, -1, 0)-- (2, -1,
0) maps into (1, 1, 2).
If we pick x_3 to be say,
1, this becomes (3, -3, 1).
So, for example, (3, -3, 1)
also maps into (1, 1, 2).
So that's the demonstration
that f bar is not one-to-one.
And the fact that nothing
maps into (1, 1, 3)
is the indication that
f bar is not onto.
By the way, by choosing a
three-dimensional space,
we can interpret this
result geometrically.
Now, what I'm
going to do here is
really optional from
your point of view.
If you don't like studies
of three-dimensional space,
ignore what I'm
saying, otherwise-- I
don't mean ignore it.
Take it with a grain
of salt. Look it over.
Read it.
It is not crucial to
understanding abstractly what's
going on.
But I thought a visual example
like this might be helpful.
Notice that when you're
mapping E^3 into E^3,
you're mapping three-dimensional
space into three-dimensional
space.
By the way, notice the
n-tuple notation here.
I prefer to write the x_1,
x_2, x_3 space rather than
the traditional x, y, z space.
In other words, f bar is
mapping x_1, x_2, x_3 space
into y_1, y_2, y_3, space.
And what we have
shown so far is that,
with our particular choice of
function under consideration
now, the only way f bar
maps something into anything
is if that anything has
what property to it?
What does the point
(y_1, y_2, y_3)
have to satisfy in order
that we can be sure
that something from the x_1,
x_2, x_3 space maps into it?
And the constraint was what?
That y_3 equals y_1 plus y_2.
Now, this is a good time to
review our equation of planes
in three-dimensional space.
Sure, we're used to talking
about z equals x plus y.
But don't worry about
that part notationally.
y_3 equals y_1 plus y_2 is
the equation of a plane.
In fact, what plane is it?
Instead of going into a
long harangue about this,
let me just find three points
that are on this plane.
In particular, (0, 0,
0) satisfies this plane.
(2, 2, 4)-- see, 2 plus 2 is 4.
1 plus 3 is 4.
So three quick points I could
pick off are the origin, (2, 2,
4), (1, 3, 4=.
These are three points not
on the same straight line.
They determine the plane.
The image of f bar is
this particular plane.
In other words, f bar does
not use up all the free space.
It, in particular, uses up
this one particular plane.
In particular, let's look
at our point (1, 1, 2).
What did we see before
mapped into (1, 1, 2)?
We saw that any 3-tuple
(x_1, x_2, x_3),
where we picked x_3 at random,
whereupon x_1 had to be x_3
plus 2, x_2 had to be
minus 2*x_3 minus 1.
Notice that this system of
equations defines a line.
You see, think of x_3 as
being a parameter here.
If it bothers you,
think of x_3 as being t.
And what you have is
that x_1 is t plus 2,
x_2 is minus 2t minus
1, and x_3 is t.
That is the parametric
form of an equation
for a straight line.
You see, notice you have only
one degree of freedom, t,
and t appears only linearly.
Now, lookit.
To find the actual straight line
geometrically, all I have to do
is find two points on that line.
To relate this with what we were
doing just previous to this,
notice that two
points that we know
are on this line are (2,
-1, 0) and (3, -3, 1).
Let's look at this graphically.
Let's locate the point
(2, -1, 0), (3, -3, 1)
in the x_1, x_2, x_3 space.
Draw the line that
joins those two points.
That line l has the property
that every single one
of these points on l map
into the point (1, 1, 2)
in the y_1, y_2, y_3 space.
In other words, our
mapping in this case
is neither one-to-one nor onto.
The entire image of this
three-dimensional space
is a single plane.
And given a point
not in that plane,
therefore, nothing
maps into that,
but given a point in that plane,
an entire line from the domain
maps in there.
And I simply point this out to
you so that for those of you
would like to have a
picture of what's happening,
I think this is a very
nice way of seeing it.
The reason I don't want to
emphasize the picture more
is simply because we will deal
in the notes and the exercises
with systems of more than three
equations and three unknowns.
We will deal with
linear mapping, say,
from E^5 into E^5,
in which case,
we can't draw the picture,
so the picture is only a nice
mental aid in setting things
up in the 2 by 2 case or the 3
by 3 case.
But other than that,
one has to rely
on the equivalent
of the matrix system
for reducing these equations.
So let me summarize, then,
what our main aim was
and what we have accomplished.
Leaving out the motivations of
everything for the time being,
let me just summarize
how we invert a matrix,
provided that the
matrix inverse exists.
Given the n by n matrix A,
we form the n by 2n matrix
A augmented by the n
by n identity matrix.
In other words,
what matrix is it?
The left half is a_1 up to
a_(1,n); a_(n,1), a_(n,n).
In other words,
it's the matrix A.
And the right half is just
the n by n identity matrix.
We then row reduce this.
Remember what mean
by row reduce--
replacing rows by the
rows plus or minus
an appropriate multiple
of another row,
hoping to get the identity
matrix to come over
to the left-hand side over here.
We row reduce this matrix.
And then what we saw was what?
We did it in the 3 by 3 case.
We're now doing it
in the n by n case.
By the way, notice that if
this throws you off abstractly,
in the 3 by 3 case, the
augmented matrix that we form
was a 3 by 6.
All we're saying is in the n
by n case, you're tacking on,
side by side, two
n by n matrices,
which makes the
resulting matrix n by 2n.
At any rate, what we do is
we reduce this n by 2n matrix
until one of two things happens.
And one of the two must happen.
Namely, either the
left-hand half-- this half--
contains at least one
row of 0's, in which case
A inverse doesn't exist.
The other alternative
is that when
we row reduce, the left-hand
side-- the left half,
in other words-- does become the
identity matrix, in which case,
the right half is A inverse.
That's all there is
to this mechanically.
You row reduce the
n by 2n matrix.
All right.
If the left-hand side
contains a row of 0's, there
is no inverse to
the given matrix.
If it reduces to
the identity matrix,
then the right half
is the inverse matrix.
Part 2 of our summary--
namely, what can we
conclude if A inverse exists?
In terms of matrix algebra, if
A inverse exists, we can solve--
in other words, we can invert
the equation Y equals A*X
to conclude that X
equals A inverse Y.
And finally, in
terms of mappings,
if we define f bar from
E sub n into E sub n--
f bar is a mapping from
n-dimensional space
into n-dimensional
space-- defined by this,
then f bar inverse exists if
and only if A inverse exists,
where A is the matrix of
coefficients over here.
And if A inverse
doesn't exist, then
f bar inverse not only
doesn't exist, but f bar
itself is neither
one-to-one nor onto.
Now, admittedly, today's
lecture was a little bit
on the long side.
It was, though, in a sense
a single concept, hopefully
with many interpretations.
It is a very, very crucial thing
in many of our investigations
to do at least
one of two things.
One thing is going
to be, we are going
to want to know whether the
inverse of a matrix exists.
In certain applications,
we will not
care to know what that
inverse matrix is.
All we're going to want
to know is, does it exist?
In that case, that's when
it's sufficient to compute
the determinant of a matrix.
Namely, if the determinant
is 0, it doesn't exist.
If the determinant is not 0,
the inverse matrix does exist.
On other occasions,
it will not be
enough to know that
the inverse exists.
We will also require that
we be able to construct
A inverse from
the given matrix A
and that, in essence,
was the lesson that we
were trying to cover today.
Starting with our
next lesson, we
will apply these results
to systems of functions
of several real variables.
And until that time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.